hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica okay so I
did a little research on the plans that
I needed here and basically all I need
to do is get a lot of materials like
titanium quartz basically I just need to
go get materials and not stop until I
have exactly enough for what I'm
supposed to be doing now I'm starting
the episode here because I just wanted
to tell you guys that and now I'm gonna
be going to do that whoa
hey how's it going air sac a little
creepy this is a little weird oh this is
limestone that I needed to break right
sure is handy there this ocean is just
chock-full of titanium that's just the
most amazing thing also there's a big
weird tunnel and I don't like it cuz it
kind of leads into somewhere that I
don't want to go I know that death
awaits me around every corner copper or
oh I found copper okay so that's the
point of digging through the limestone
is that it actually has more materials
than just titanium I mean now that I've
gotten over my initial fear I haven't
got over my fear absolutely about this
place got me inventories for God how far
away to from home did I go okay so I
need to start venturing that way before
I can go anywhere else yeah like this is
so cool like I mean from a game
standpoint this is actually really
really cool like there's a lot to do
here there's a lot to see and I've only
scratched the surface so you're ready
for me to bumble around for a few more
episodes before I call it quits is this
place getting more smoky that's probably
not good ah
oh cool mobile power source that sounds
fancy am i drifting thought I was
drifting how about a small storage cube
what do I do with that it's absolutely
nothing and it's invisible free up some
space to pick up the small storage cube
what does it even mean oh my supposed to
do that forget this I picked up these
stupid-ass mushrooms I didn't need him
in the first place
done and done decomposing cooked
oh that was well that was bad I didn't
know it was bad hey my storage Kubb give
me my cool Bey back this is so silly and
stupid yo yo - yo - Thank You yo 3 come
here don't run away from me you know you
want to be cooked
does that go to fish I got it I'm so
thankful that you're caring about my
well-being computer wife but at this
point I've got it that is not how is it
helpful how is that helpful
that's not stores since is taking up
space oh hello whoa I didn't know there
were Birds
get back here birds I got my knife and
it's a bouncy little bouncy wants to
stab you you got water drinkable ok
goodbye we're gonna have a good time
down here the ocean we don't need those
sky flyers we're down here where it's
better where it's wetter that's how the
saying goes
don't question me god damn it this
frickin store I don't need this screw
the storage cube scorch cube is stupid
and I hate it I'm going to just get more
courts and more sale veg sale vag is all
I need
I don't know what the salt deposit is
for 30 seconds of oxygen we love 30
seconds oh that's so dangerous oh thank
you computer wife I guess I should name
you at some point
what did plankton name his computer wife
I can't remember Karen that's a Karen
Karen stop it now the knife no good or
I'm not strong enough because I'm about
to die from severe dehydration
oh I don't like that it's an unknown
there's more of them oh I didn't see him
I'm out howdy howdy
I'm out howdy Audi Audi where the hell
are all the fish there were supposed to
be more air sacks I haven't seen any in
a while oh I didn't know that I can oh I
just mean air sac oh I didn't know that
I could do that oh oh it's gonna be dark
okay where is an air sac I need an air
sac real bad like real bad there's one
come here you
I got you I have a need for you hang on
I have a need free oh god are those
scary I mean they are to me but are they
bad question more quartz
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
no thank you no thank you no thank you
I'm okay don't need oh god this is the
thingies oh I don't like the thingies I
don't even uh where's a goddamn air sac
is that all I got I'm gonna die
dehydration ah yeah yeah yeah there we
go
okay so now I got per Wilder Verdugo if
I known that I would have done that I
would have done that a long time ago
okay
that's dark whoa
oh the noises start right away don't
they well alrighty then but I've got a
flashlight and I've got balls of steel
so don't even try to do anything are you
oh that sounds very bad emergency oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god wasn't paying attention come
on don't die oh I thought that was gonna
die like instantly okay
it's almost daytime I made it through
the night and I got to poop or fish
I don't know why they're called pooper
fish but I can't wait to try them in my
mouth hole yeah okay
enough creepy okay so the main point is
I have the ability and the blueprints to
make a building and that's what I want
to do next it's time to finally face off
with what you're doing by the way
welcome back I'm actually gonna go whoa
I don't like you
Oh God you just blow up oh that's so
scary I'm almost dead that's not cool oh
my god that is horrible
I didn't know that's what would happened
before I was scared for good reason then
holy crap okay so besides almost dying I
have the capability to do what I need to
do so I just have to find out how to do
it so five this looks like relatively
flat ground I'm clicking on it trying to
press buttons on it like what do you
want from me
I'm not leaving till I find out how to
do you not like a seconds of oxygen
remaining
ah there's gotta be a way oh okay I need
a tool I need a tool for it I need
something called the Builder okay so it
wasn't just me being very stupid it was
only me being slightly stupid and not
seeing in the tool second there was
something called a builder I should
probably look through so what I need to
do is I need to be able to make a
computer chip first is the first thing
that I need and I need to can do that by
doing some
something here computer chip okay table
coral sample oh I know what that is in
silver ore okay so I got to dig around
until I find silver oral and then I know
where yeah I got you okay so I need oh
god I need so many things okay so the
first thing I can do there's table coral
right here there we go so I just slice
oh that's what it wanted me to do okay
so it like it just literally just wanted
me to slice at it with my knife oh that
makes more sense because the other thing
that I had was there was uh there was
the the the the thought I didn't know
that the right-click actually sliced it
until I was trying to hit the fish okay
this is my titanium whole boo boo boo
boo boo boo boo okay bye-bye titanium
you be good I'll come back for you I
love you Karen don't listen I'm not I'm
just lying to him to make you feel
better
Karen come on computer wife it's gonna
be okay there's far more titanium than I
actually need is what I guess coral so
well what did that what was that what
did that what that happen was it revenge
I'm about to die I can't have this death
are you oh you're probably way too fast
I need like the the air bladders I need
air sacs there's not enough air sacs yes
I could have gotten it if I'd have felt
like it titanium there seem to be a lot
of noises coming from deep in this
cavern I don't think I want to find out
what they're to come here you come here
you come here you
yeah gotcha that's a big noise I'm
imagining it's coming from a big fish
Oh inventory full of course it is
creepvine sampling bleach I don't know
where to get bleach do I send millions
bleach coral sample okay so bleach and
creepvine and bleach it is that is scary
oh I'm out in the deep ocean I don't
like it give me your creepiness thank
you Oh God inventory full drop drop more
titanium I don't care at this point I
get too many coral samples but I need no
not more okay I got enough okay that's
enough okay then I got two fish that'll
skeet me until I can at least heal up
and then I can get more fish maybe I can
grab one on the way my inventory is not
falling grab two more oh there's gonna
be cutting in close guys but I can do it
I know it you believe in me all the
comment sections are cheering me on I
can feel it in my bones I can feel it in
my butt I can feel a lot of things in my
weight I can't feel a lot of things I'm
gonna ignore that about my but just keep
cheering me on ignore the crazy
ramblings that I'm saying I'm very
dehydrated don't mind me SEC the ocean
completely ran out of bladders
okay there we go there's that personal I
need to make bleach which is right here
okay now I can make first-aid kit which
is right there and kaboom yes okay now
we're getting somewhere now I'm not
doing so terribly huh no no I'm still
doing pretty bad I need a lot of water
and there's like no air sacks and then I
still need the Builder tool
I just need silver for that so before I
do that alright so I got that okay I got
the table coral and I got the
decomposing green fine yeah creepvine
gives even less water oh oh I just need
bleach oh oh I need more salt deposit oh
I didn't know that I could get oh I
didn't I didn't know that I could get
water from just bleach oh I could pay
attention but I don't where do I get
salt deposit I don't know where those I
don't know if those just spawn
everywhere or I don't know they're very
small I don't often see them salty
yo come here you come on come here ah
there we go you turn that was your main
mistake you you're mine yes I don't know
what you are but you're weird and gross
and I need salt but I without salt I
might as well eat every sea creature I
come across that's just good right need
water very delirious of course I might
be delirium for meeting all these
strange sea creatures they are very
alien and probably made up with a very
different substance from what I am yes
new creatures any water that I can make
nope okay floral flavor
see cartilaginous fins cooked peeper got
a bunch of these
now okay nom-nom-nom-nom there we go a
little better not doing great but doing
a little better okay I'm gonna get this
builder is it gonna take a while because
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to
get silver or leave control what I get
that's better can I eat coral can I just
eat coral please I just want it okay
alright so we're doing better we're
doing we're not doing great but we're
doing better so if I can just get more
salt that I can make more bleach which I
didn't know that I can make water from
that so that's what I'm going for next
so thank you everybody so much for
watching in the next episode I will
start building my base and I will start
surviving stuff a little bit better than
I had before well thanks again and as
always I'll see you in the next video
and know